because it's april fool's day we're
going to draft the all-time great nfl
trick plays chris i'll give you the
first pick all-time great trick plays
inspired by april fools all right well i
think the the the best trick play in in
my opinion in the history of football
the gutsiest best ever i'm going to go
with sean payton and the onside kick
to start the second half against in the
super bowl against the colts that to me
was just
an unbelievable moment in nfl history
for me you know it was one of those
games where you kept looking at go man
this is a great game this is close the
colts look a little bit better than the
saints you know the saints are going to
have to do something to pull this off
and there it was to start the second
second half and then like i think what's
crazy in it as you're watching here
do you remember how long this melee went
on where they s
scrambled for the football this whole
time i mean it was like life or death
i'm telling you this is five minutes
later they've been underneath the scrum
going at it doing it all
i just remember the intensity of the
moment to go along with it but sean
payton i mean wow what a call
yeah absolutely and uh one of the
problems with the new onside kick
formation it's it's uh unlikely that we
will see plays like that in the future
my first pick chris i didn't i can't
believe you didn't pick this one what
trick play actually resulted in a statue
being erected outside of the team's home
stadium it was the philly special the
conversation between nick foles and doug
peterson when he walks over to the
sideline they decide to do the philly
special
that's the play from super bowl 52 even
though it was in the first half didn't
decide the game or anything but it was
one of those moments where it made you
think man the patriots may actually lose
this game to the philadelphia eagles
look it put them up 10 points going into
the break we've seen this thing
imitated and duplicated and they stole
it from someone else but that's okay
that's what football's all about and
that statue was put outside the stadium
and both nick foles and doug peterson
are long gone from philadelphia that's
what makes it even crazier it is crazy i
mean they did it against the patriots
the patriots had done a similar play
earlier and brady dropped it right i
mean there's so many things there
let alone yeah we just don't see people
do that to the patriots i mean is it
it it it is it is a bud light statue
outside of the
uh right isn't it i don't know it's
still a statue still a statue okay all
right all right i'll give it an official
statue fine clarification there that i
just wanted to make sure all right
um
i think i'm gonna go with old dan marino
as my next one the fake spike okay i was
gonna make this an all giants fake fake
plays thing i'll get to one of those in
a minute but dan marino fake spike you
know back against the new york jets it
says 1981 afc divisional i don't think
that's correct this is early 90s um no
yeah dan marino was at pitt in 1981
right so that would be a type i think
we're getting our trick place mixed up
this is probably the looking ladder from
the dolphins that yes but either way
this was one of those moments i could
still there's aaron glenn defensive
coordinator of the detroit lions i could
still remember watching this on tv and
just going wow and i know a lot of
people right now might go well what's
the big deal nobody had ever done this
at that point that was the first time
ever we saw a guy going clock clock
clock clock and then wait and all of a
sudden he threw a touchdown and nobody
had done that now that's become
commonplace with our nfl it's literally
you say clock and you make sure the
guy's playing defense because we've
taught the receiver to still run a route
in case the guy falls asleep with the
wheel so we see that from time to time
but that was the first ever and uh great
trickeration by danny marino
that was the 94 regular season it was a
key game in the division in the chase
for the afc's championship and it's so
common now that on madden they have the
spike play and the fake spike that's
right
all right uh next one for me the randall
l touchdown pass he's now the receiver's
coach in detroit you mentioned the
defensive coordinator in detroit from
our last clip antoine randall l throwing
the touchdown pass of course he was the
indiana quarterback to heinz ward who
would be the mvp of super bowl 40
uh cementing the victory over the
seattle seahawks that's my second pick
what else you got yeah that was big i
mean they needed it too right i mean
that was a game where big ben was
severely struggling throwing the
football and doing that uh bill cower i
mean that's a gutsy play call for him
the two talented guys all right um i got
i got two giants ones on my list you
know there's that great 1990 nfc
championship fake punt to gary reasons
right that up the middle against joe
montana the niners but i'm gonna go with
one that
hits a little closer to home i'm going
to the 1986 super bowl super bowl 21 the
phil sims flea flicker to phil mcconkey
i mean bill parcells like bill belichick
just great guts and big moments to call
plays like this but this play ended up
with yes mcconkey helicoptering down to
the one yard line uh and and this was
really the start of the onslaught and it
already kind of had begun there but now
to where you go oh the giants are gonna
blow the broncos out certainly a special
play to my family and uh gives me chills
to this day
last one for me not a trick play but a
trick game when the wildcat was
unleashed in 2008 by the 0-2 dolphins
against the patriots and
ronnie brown running
the wildcat as the quarterback accounted
for five touchdowns in a 38-13 win over
the patriots and it ushered the whole
wildcat phenomenon chris into the nfl
for what
three or four years definitely it was
everyone had a package that was premised
on the wildcat yeah and we we used it
against the patriots and the broncos
josh mcdaniels knew the checks of the
wildcat and we faked the wildcat when we
played them that year because we knew we
could get them in the defense they that
we wanted to get them in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports